hello and welcome to this video balázs
recall FISMA poland okay yeah that's not
bad actually
u5 pretty pretty ok line for black yeah
definitely a playable option so yeah you
don't really have much gym with white I
try to play on control of the square on
c4 but this is really not all that much
like it's I'm having d5 as well so I
have control over c4 but she's got
something in return
okay um young probably developed this
currently hmm I can take one of six now
yeah what is that but this maybe Bishop
officially five Queen takes is excellent
for me so I'm not worried about dad all
that much it's just like I don't know
what his next move is Knight you cannot
move the knight and yeah this is a
possible next move for sure okay I
wanted to go there anyway
so take take take on these several
checks okay
I have knight c6 in this position I
wonder if that leads to anything that's
if that's my my issue I don't know let's
just be very technical about it yeah
this is some equal
okay not sure if that is useful yeah I'm
probably not I have this nice piece on
c4 but I cannot do much with it I mean
it doesn't have a clear idea what your
tech has the problem may be you know in
an ending a Knight to c6 something could
be annoying
okay what I can do is I can try to play
on the kingside given that on the grass
or play drew c'mon if I get the chance I
can try to play on the kingside a little
bit because on the queenside there's
definitely not much happening it's just
I've blocked that quite reliably okay
Knight to g4 is that a maneuver that
helps probably not
yeah what about this ending it's
probably equal huh it's probably equal
what can I do anything if I go here
they'll probably take you there's just
nothing
and wonder if he will play root deform
that could be okay it doesn't do that
after that maybe I would have had slight
hopes with the night coming to c6 I'm
not a regrouping this and see what he
does here I can bring the knight to e3
that probably doesn't do anything then
it's not quite clear that I actually get
there so the Roku maneuver is just
completely leading to nothing okay
Vinnie I need some need to be patient
here it is just equal and you have to
see what happens Oh
hmmm it's not helping us bishop
Miette maybe it doesn't matter but
woopsie for Bishop to e7 as what he
wants to do some ganja rather bring it
to c4 again if I was a bit odd really we
had that that was a good move
[Music]
ya know get the king pin get the king
over interesting hmm I will take it
doesn't improve his pawn structure all
that much he has aged 5 but
[Music]
I had it was good you okay whatever I
try your cos has a good a good idea
against it nicely played public
yeah yeah that that's that nights not
really doing all that much
yeah that is that is actually I know
that's involving some risk iam what I'm
doing
and wait if he blunders something I
should take it you know there was just
nothing going on I think if anybody
maybe he was better yeah that is a good
a good set up for black it's just what
it is and this kind of thing I've looked
at this quite a bit and you don't ever
have anything in the structure I so I'm
try it with just just nothing yeah maybe
I shouldn't have played a b3 likening it
like that hmm I think we are dealing
with a completely equal position the
whole time the engine might give a small
edge for one of one of us but it is
mostly just just equal it's interesting
our e5 wasn't move that I found strange
relief that that is a weird move he
makes his own bishop worse but it's
possible that it doesn't really matter
all that much
yeah rookie 294 is stronger but I'm not
sure that I can do much how am i
changing the pawn structure
I cannot go f4 and I know deform no c3
and if you cannot change the pawn
structure you're going nowhere f1 yeah
FY 5 is something I could have done but
it's still I think it's just a draw we
mostly just kept the game going without
either side having much what say yeah
just draw oh it's just a draws from
which is very drawing both sides are
just sitting I've tried it look good but
the tip doesn't really eat anything
hmm yeah now I'm a little bit bad I am
if he goes here what he should do of
course then here and ruku I'm a little
bit better now because that Paulin
advance was a bit untimely and then he
heel blundered into the into the for hmm
yeah there was a bit of a lucky winner
after having no advantage whatsoever
yeah thanks a lot for watching